the ladies of the Kids Choice Awards  waited on Kim's hashtag liberated nude  selfie we had to find out would they do  it themselves not personally but that's  my choice I think it's your choice to  love your body the way you feel you you  see fit so I choose to do something she  chose to do another thing you know which  is empowering it's loving yourself and  being free to do whatever you want with  your own body yeah I mean she wasn't  nude she had like the black strip so I  thought her body look banging it was  just like wearing a bikini and Meghan  Trainor's new song no is the debut  single off her upcoming album thank you  she tells et who to expect oh my mom is  featured on my album a song called my  mom it's called mom and I called her and  she's talking to me and saying she loves  me and that's the bridge so I guess it's  all in there